now that phase four of the MCU has been
officially revealed and Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios has
mentioned mutants come into the MCU the
future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is getting more and more exciting how's
it going everybody it's Warren and the
x-men come into the MCU is one of the
most exciting things that we can talk
about and something that we've all been
waiting for for a very long time now and
luckily for us it doesn't seem like
we're going to have to wait that much
longer to see x-men or mutants in the
MCU and this is something that we've all
been talking about for a while now and
again Kevin Feige mentioned it at San
Diego comic-con and the Russo brothers
have recently commented on the x-men
entering the MCU as well in fact they've
even expressed interest in directing a
Wolverine film in the MCU and they've
even recently talked about which x-men
survived the snap and which ones got
dusted so I'll break down the Russo
brothers wanting to direct a Wolverine
film in the MCU and which x-men they
said got dusted real quick if you'd like
a chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 be
sure to subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment with your
favorite superhero or villain for your
chance to enter I'll be picking a winner
at 500,000 subscribers so prior to the
Disney Fox deal the x-men in the MCU was
something that just couldn't happen so
any talked before about an x-men movie
coming to the MCU was just wishful
thinking including when it came from
people at Marvel they could talk about
the x-men in the MCU all they wanted to
but until the Disney Fox deal was done
they couldn't actually do it however now
they can make a movie with the x-men in
them and according to Kevin Feige they
are and now it seems like the Russo
brothers who directed Captain America
the Winter Soldier Captain America Civil
War Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame may go on at some point to
direct a Wolverine film recently in many
Avengers and Game interviews they've
talked about Wolverine and what's really
interesting is that prior to the Disney
Fox deal being complete in a Q&A with
Collider the Russo brothers were asked
which film could bring them back to
directing a film in the MCU and they
replied with Secret Wars but now the
Disney Fox deal is done and Marvel can
talk about the x-men in MCU films or
solo films of their own and now in an
official ask me anything on reddit with
the Russo brothers they were asked which
superhero movie they would like to
direct that is not in
MC you yet and they replied with
Wolverine now again before this was just
wishful thinking but given the massive
success that Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game had it would make sense
that Marvel would want to keep the Russo
brothers around and now fortunately for
us Marvel can use the x-men in the MCU
which is what the Russo brothers wanted
they want to direct a wolverine film and
according to some things they've said in
other films they've actually thought
about what could happen in a recent
interview they were asked which x-men
got snapped and which x-men survived the
snap and their answer was actually quite
shocking out of all the x-men they were
given to choose from they said all of
the x-men got snapped except for
Wolverine and the interview the team was
gambit gene gray storm Wolverine Cyclops
and rogue and the Russo brothers killed
all of them except for Wolverine and
according to jewelry so they had a
pretty good reason to do that Joe Russo
said that he'd love to see a fiercely
motivated Wolverine going up against
Thanos eliminating all of the x-men
except for Wolverine would have most
likely made a lot of people mad and Joe
Russo acknowledged this but explained
why it needed to happen he said it's not
his job to give the people what they
want it's to give them what they need
and I think we all need to see Wolverine
go absolutely crazy on famous now
Avengers endgame has already happened so
unfortunately we won't see a Wolverine
vs. Thanos at least not anytime soon
they could always bring back fan o's and
I actually have many ideas about how
they could but we know that the x-men
are coming to the MCU that is official
right from the president of Marvel
Studios himself but now the question is
how are they going to bring the x-men
into the MCU are they going to introduce
them all at once or are they going to
introduce one first and if it's only one
Wolverine is the perfect candidate and
the Russo brothers have great interest
in directing a Wolverine film and they
have directed four of the best MCU films
again including Avengers infinity war
and endgame so it would make sense that
Marvel would want them to tackle
introducing the mutants into the MCU
given their massive success they would
be absolutely perfect for the job and
now since the Disney Fox deal is done it
is an absolute possibility we know
Marvel we know how they work they like
to keep everything under wraps they like
to trick us they like to keep us in the
dark but again we do know that
the mutants are coming so could it be
that the Russo brothers are already
lined up to direct a Wolverine film
coming to the MCU this is just my
speculation for now but based on
everything that we've heard it seems
like it could be possible so let me know
what you think about this in the
comments down below and comment below
with who you would like to see play
Wolverine in the MCU also don't forget
to comment with your favorite superhero
or villain liked this video and
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
my giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
one or a ps4 I'm also giving away some
blu-ray copies of Avengers in game on my
Instagram and Twitter so be sure to
follow me on there for a chance to win
as well as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof